good morning Hank it's Tuesday greetings
from the White River here in
Indianapolis I am headed to a cool place
in my kayak that almost nobody knows
about and I would like to show it to you
so one of the things that fascinates me
about river islands is that they don't
really belong to anyone and they aren't
of much human utility because their only
land part of the time but one of the
many paradoxes of the white river is
that the islands uselessness to others
is precisely what makes it useful to me
like I love it because nobody goes there
another of the rivers great paradoxes is
that it appears pristine and beautiful
in part because it is so filthy like raw
sewage dumps into the white river many
times a year which is one of the main
reasons why nobody comes down here but I
find it's not that bad as long as you
don't swim in the water or expose it to
open wounds you're mostly fine like in
five years of being on the white river
I've only gotten Giardia twice we are
finally getting close to wallet Island
of course I've been going downstream
this whole time so the way back is gonna
take about three times as long and it's
gonna be about one-fifth as much fun but
that's okay it'll still be some fun so
welcome to wallet island my favorite
place it's both very loud and very quiet
very private nobody else's here and also
very public it's in the center of the
12th largest city in the United States
the island feels natural but it isn't
most of these are invasive plants and
also the island is deeply shaped by the
phenomenally dirty water that rolls over
it with every flood I named it wallet
island by the way because I once found a
wallet here that's not its official name
in fact I don't even know if it has an
official name as you can see there's
lots of trees on wild island mostly
sycamore trees but also some oak trees
there's tons of plant life but the thing
about this island is that it floods like
every few weeks and then it becomes a
completely new island there's a
completely new set of driftwood lying
around a different set of trash there's
always a lot of trash and so every time
I come here I feel like I'm discovering
a new place I can sit here for hours if
bring my computer here I can write but
critically I can't get online so it's a
place of contradictions but I also think
it's a place of beauty all right come on
I'll show you around in case you're
wondering if dandelions can even make
their way here yes they can man it's bad
enough to drink Bud Light seltzer but to
throw it in the river
it's just classless when the water is
flooding and coming downstream all this
stuff gets pressed up against the trees
and so you get these weird Beaver Dam
looking things that are half natural and
is that a bench it was a bench it's
actually a really good venture I'm gonna
have a seat
well that Island now has a seating area
but anyway some of these collections
have fallen wood can just be wildly
beautiful
I'm also very fond of this chair which
has been here for a year this is a chair
called a monoblock chair which is one of
the most common chairs in the world like
you've sat in a chair like this and you
see them all over the world including
apparently wallet island if you're
wondering what happens when you leave
your straw by the side of the road it
ends up in the river Hank I just
discovered an unopened can of Budweiser
beer that is good until June 5th 2020
which is two days ago I went to pick up
that bottle but it had pee in it so I
think I'm gonna leave it where it is
okay I'm gonna pack up some trash and
begin my two-hour paddle upstream Hank
I'll see you on Friday